المقابل دعت الحكومه الفرنسيه الاحزاب
والقوى السياسيه الى ادانه العنف واكد
بيان للحكومه ان فرنسا ستبقى حصنا ضد ما
وصفه بالعنف والمجموعات المتطرفه العنيفه
واشار البيان الى ان المظاهرات لا ينبغي
ان تتحول الى العنف وان الخطاب السياسي
يجب ان يبقى منضبطا واضاف بيان الحكومه
الفرنسيه انه لا توجد وساطه مع اي طرف في
وقت يمكن فيه الحديث بشكل مباشر مع جميع
الفرنسيين
معنى من باريس مراسل الجزيره لطفي
المسعودي لطفي انت تتابع منذ ساعات كيف
تطورت الامور
عثمان منذ تقريبا نصف ساعه من الان طلبت
من الشرطه ان نتراجع الى احد الشوارع
الجانبيه المطله على ساحه
الامه وقامت بحمله لتفريق المتظاهرين في
الساحه استعملت فيها يعني كميات كبيره من
القنابل المسيله للدموع الى ان عددا من
المتظاهرين قاموا برشقها بما ارسلته
باتجاههم يعني كما تلاحظ خلفي لا اعرف ان
كنت تلاحظ جيدا او ترى ان رجال الشرطه
الان اصبحوا يسيطرون تقريبا على ربع ساحه
الامه ويتقدمون تدريجيا في محاوله لتفريق
المتظاهرين في هذه الساحه عثمان منذ قليل
لاحظنا ان رجال الشرطه كانوا ياخذون عددا
من من اعتقلوهم في ساحه الامه هنا الى هذه
السيارات المرابطه حدونا هنا في يعني في
هذا الشارع المتاخمي لساحه الامه
وبالتثبت من المعلومات التي وصلتنا عبر
وكالات الانباء بلغ عدد من تم اعتقالهم في
باريس لوحدها اليوم عثمان قرابه سبعا
وعشرين
ربما حسابيا نضيف لهم اثنين لاحظنا انهما
منذ اقل من خمس دقائق كما اعتقالهما في
المكان بشكل افضل ما نلاحظه للشرطه الصور
التي نراها فيها يعني الشرطه واكاد لا ارى
اي متظاهرين تقريبا هل ما حدث هو ان الوقت
المخصص للمظاهره المرخصه انتهى فغادر
المتظاهرون امكن هناك تفريق بالقوه
نعم نطفي تسمعني
كان يقول لطفي فعلا اظن انه كان سيتفق مع
ما قلته لان الوقت نعم تفضل تفضل اكمل
لطفي تفضل نعم انا اسمعك جيدا
عثمان ما حدث هو ان الشرطه طلبت منا
المغادره لانها كانت تقوم بحمله لتفريق
المتظاهرين ولكن المتظاهرون لم يغادروا عن
بكره ابيهم ساحه الامه لان الشرطه مثلما
الاحظه انا من هنا هي تحتل تقريبا ربع
ساحه الامه اما المساحه الباقيه ما زال
يرابط فيها عدد كبير جدا من المتظاهرين
وخاصه من فئه الشباب عثمان في الايام
الماضيه وخاصه يعني
ليله يعني تمرير قانون التقاعد الجديد
باعتماد
الفقره الثالثه من الفصل 49 من الدستور
خرجت عدد من المظاهرات العشوائيه الليليه
عنيفه الى حد ما طبعا الميزه لهذه
المظاهرات هي كثافه وجود عنصر الشباب ما
نلاحظه الان هو اختفاء شبه كلي للكحول
المتقدمين في السن وما نلاحظه هو وجود عدد
كبير من المراهقين ومن الشبان في ساحه
الامه وهم يعني الشرطه تواجه صعوبات في
تفريقهم لان عددا كبيرا منهم رغم
ملاحظاتهم ان عددا اخر من المتظاهرين تم
اعتقالهم من قبل الشرطه الا انهم متمتسين
بساحه الامه ويرفضون مغادرتها عثمان ولا
نعرف ما هو السيناريو المقبل من اجل ان
ينفض هذا الحشد الشعبي هنا في ساحه لان
رجال الشرطه يتقدمون ببطء في الساحه يعني
هذه المظاهرات اساسها هو الموضوع قانون
التقاعد ولكن الحكومه يبدو انها يعني ابدت
استعدادا للحوار
ولكن ليس عن قانون التقاعد الذي هو اصلا
اساس هذه الاحتجاجات
فعلا عثمان الحكومه تطرح يعني الحوار من
اجل مساء المتعلقه بالتشغيل والبيئه وكذلك
باعاده توطين الصناعه في فرنسا وكذلك خاصه
عن ظروف العمل يعني كطرديه ولكن النقابات
متمسكه بضروره ان حدث هنالك تواصل ونقاش
بين الزعامات النقابيه في فرنسا وبين
الحكومه ان يتطرق اولا الى هذا القانون
الخلافي بين النقابات والحكومه والذي ترفض
النقابات تمريره رغم ان الحكومه قد قامت
فعليا يعني بالخطوات القانونيه من اجل
تبنيه ولم يبقى الا راي المجلس الدستوري
الذي سوف يصدر في غضون اسبوعين الى ثلاثه
اسابيع من الان عثمان ولكن رد النقابات
يظهر في تحديد يوما 11 من ايام التعبئه
الوطنيه في فرنسا وعثمان بعد اتفاقهم مساء
اليوم بين النقابات الثمن الرئيسيه على
تنظيم يوم 11 من المظاهرات والاضراب سوف
يكون يوم السادس من ابريل القادم عثمان
شكرا لك على اجمال ما يحدث هناك في باريس
لطفي المسعودي مراسل الجزيره متحدثا الينا
من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس